let's see how to deplane a little app on  Google compute engine using cloud tools  for visual studio first go to tools and  extensions and updates and install  google cloud tools for visual studio  once installed go to google cloud tools  and manage accounts and add your goal  cloud account now go to Google Cloud  Explorer and select your project and  then create a new asp.net instance this  opens cloud launcher where you can  deploy compute engine instance with  Windows Server is cycle server and  expert and framework installed once  compute engine instance is ready create  a new Windows user finally right-click  on your asp.net  app and select publish to Google Cloud  so that compute engine choose the VM  instance and the windows account that  you want to use to publish in a few  seconds your app will be deployed to  compute engine